When the world drifts away from our eyes.
Say, on one of a thousand nights.
There begins a dream within a dream.
I watch you with a hundred thousand eyes, Istanbul.
My leaves flutter and beat like a hundred thousand hearts.
The wisteria vine in full blossom.
Fruit reddening on the bough.
I'm local.
Like a slice of Trabzon cheese.
A tuft of mohair.
A pinch of rye.
A handful of Sile cotton.
I recalled Borges's dreamlike tale.
One morning by the Aegean.
See there on the shores.
One by one, waves start blue.
Then spread purple across the seas.
Facing the sea of sparkling waves.
Laid-back in knee-deep waters.
I smile at you all in good will.